we begin with a tragic milestone reached
on Tuesday in the United States more
than 1 million Americans have now
contracted the corona virus that's
according to the tally kept by Johns
Hopkins University well than 58,000
Americans have died from kovat 19 the
disease caused by the virus now proof of
how quickly the virus has spread on
April 10 the number of cases in the u.s.
stood at 500,000 but it took just 18
days for that figure to double all the
while US president Trump facing
criticism and questions for what he did
and didn't do to stop the virus like
many other countries in the early days
of the pandemic the United States was in
denial about the true danger of the
corona virus it's going to disappear one
day it's like a miracle it will
disappear thank you but the miracle
didn't happen and the prayer didn't help
certainly not in states like New York
covet 19 hit the Big Apple hard
hospitals were soon filled to capacity
and morgues were overwhelmed State
Governor Andrew Cuomo entered crisis
mode and issued a warning to the rest of
the country New York is in crisis help
New York and then pick up decamp and
then go to the next place as this rolls
across the country a prediction that
turned out to be true the virus spread
rapidly from coast to coast by early
April it was impossible to deny the
seriousness of the situation
[Music]
we're in a very critical phase of our
war against the coronavirus the
sacrifices we make over the next four
weeks will have countless American lives
saved we're going to save a lot of
American lives and were in control of
our own fate very much so
despite the sacrifices within a week the
United States led the world in covert 19
deaths it still tops the grim list
confirmed infections have now topped the
1 million mark a milestone that nobody
wanted to reach at a time when calls to
reopen the country are growing louder
beaches and California were already
packed at the weekend and several cities
and states are preparing to loosen
stay-at-home restrictions well let's
explore this further and bring in our
correspondent Stefan Simmons in
Washington Stefan the u.s. topped 1
million and makes up one third of all
the confirmed coronavirus cases in the
world
why has the u.s. been hit so hard well I
wish there was an easy and not
complicated answer for this but it is
rather complicated and complex and it's
not easy to answer however most
importantly it is what many many says
that the administration slept through or
was really really really really slow to
respond to a growing threat of
coronavirus in the United States and as
it turns out we now know that the virus
was already making its way infiltrating
and going through the public here in the
US in late January not in late February
or mid-february as thought before and it
was Donald Trump of the Trump
administration who for a long time in
February as you just saw in the piece
also said underplayed all of this and
and said this won't be a problem at all
now it is a problem we need in the
United States massive texting that's
what testing that's what the experts say
we're at 200,000 tests per day at the
moment
experts say 5 million
tests per day are necessary we actually
figure out where this virus is how much
and how deeply it infiltrated the u.s.
populace here and only then we can start
to reopen businesses safely and be aware
of or be sure to be rid of coronavirus
okay Stefan president Trump as you said
has kept on saying that he's got
everything under control now the US has
hit this this mark this grim mark what
does it all say about his crisis
management well there's lots of people
here observers and across the political
spectrum by the way and of course a lot
of citizens and experts who saying like
this is not a prime performance from the
administration to the contrary just
because the president says there's
enough tests just because the president
says there is he and his work saved
millions of lives that may be so however
the death rate is now at 58,000 people
that 58,000 people and just a month or a
little bit more than that
the president said like 15 cases and all
will go away so another example the vice
president showing up today at the Mayo
Clinic in Minnesota without a mask
surrounded by experts and doctors and
patients with the mask and he's not
wearing a mask that is exemplary for how
many many people and experts see this
handling of the Trump administration the
handling of the coronavirus crisis and
well they can't and are not very happy
with the administration okay thank you
Stefan Simmons in Washington